aux endroits où la terre s'enfonce dans
les eaux en apic la zone qui sépare les
marais est évidemment beaucoup plus
réduite les créatures qui y vivent sont
constamment en proie à deux dangers à la
ligne de marée haute il y a le risque de
s'échouer sur le sol et 2,6 dessécher et
à la ligne de marée basse il y a le
risque de se faire attraper par des
animaux venant des profondeurs
chaque espèce vivant sur ce terrain
étroit développe des forces qui lui
permettent de compenser ses points
faibles
certains ne pouvant supporter qu'un bref
séjour à l'air libre vive haut niveau le
plus bas possible comme l'oursin qui se
nourrit d'algues hors de l'eau il n'a
d'autre solution que de s'accrocher
provisoirement rocher c'est ce que font
également ses anémones de mer géante qui
replie leurs tentacules car à l'air
libre
elle ne capte rien à manger et les
ascidies ne peuvent filtrer l'eau et
s'alimenter qu'épisodiquement des
étoiles de mer sont carnivores
celle-ci se nourrissent de moules elle
les recouvre de leurs bras pourvus de
petites ventouses et force lentement
leur copie pour l'aider or en dessous de
la ligne de marée basse
aucune moule n'y résiste mais comme
beaucoup de créatures de cette zone une
fois sorti de l'eau les étoiles de mer
sont impuissantes à s'alimenter
les moules choisissent donc pour
s'installer des rochers exposé
alternativement au flot et à l'air libre
les moules ne peuvent résister à des
vagues très violente aux endroits les
plus exposés
elles sont remplacées par les balles
anne petit crustacé fixé qui ont une
plus grande résistance
ainsi chaque parent de la rive est
envahi par des organismes les mieux
adaptés à ces combinaisons très précise
de condition physique et biologique
le mouvement incessant de la mère finit
par réduire les rochers de la côte en
sable que le flou déposera au bord des
baies abriter ici vivent d'autres
communautés intermédiaire un petit
nombre seulement s'aventure au dessus de
la ligne de marée haute
c'est le cas de torture qui sont
contraints dans quelque sorte par
atavisme
celle ci est une lépi doc ellis du
pacifique avec ses 60 70 cm de long elle
est sans doute la plus petite des
tortues de mer comme toutes ses
congénères elle descend de reptiles
terrestres et c'est eux ne peuvent
toujours se développer qu'à l'air libre
après s'être accoupler en mer elle
débarque donc sur la côte pour répondre
au costa rica ce débarquement ressemble
à une véritable invasion au rythme de
5000 tortue à l'heure et seulement sur
deux ou trois plages qu'elles se sont
choisis parmi les centaines que compte
la région
plus surprenant encore elle n'envahisse
ainsi les plages que pendant certaines
nuits en nous et novembre si leurs
nageoires sont efficaces en mer au sol
elle ne leur sont que d'un piètre usage
elles sont à peine capable de l'être
année sur le sable cette ponte massive
et sporadique est une protection pour
les yeux qui sont ainsi moins menacés
par les prédateurs
chaque femelle pond une centaine de pour
des raisons mal connu rarement plus d'un
de ses senteurs produira un petit qui
regagnera ensuite la mer
sur d'autres plages plus discrètement
d'autres tortue très différentes ont
entamé leur pente
celles ci sont les plus grande de toutes
les tortues marines ce sont les
splendides tortue luth la tortue luth
est un animal très mystérieux c'est un
vagabond solitaire des océans
on en trouve pratiquement dans toutes
les zones tropicales et d'autres ont été
signalés très loin de là en argentine
dans les îles britanniques ou encore en
amérique du nord
on sait très peu de choses d'elle sinon
qu'elle se nourrit d'oursins de mer et
de poissons
mais elle est aussi très friande de
méduses
on ignore la durée moyenne de vie ces
tortues luth
on ne sait rien de leurs habitudes
d'accouplement on ne sait pas non plus
comment les femelles s'oriente pour
trouver leurs sites traditionnels de
ponte en fait
jusqu'il ya trente ans on n'en avait
jamais découvert la reproduction de ces
mastodontes restait un mystère complet
depuis lors on a repéré quelques unes
des plages où elles pondent sur la côte
du surinam en amérique du sud est ici et
sur la côte est de la malaisie les
populations locales elles étaient bien
entendu au courant de leur présence et l
pillet d'ailleurs leurs oeufs
c'est une pratique qui n'a pas disparu
malheureusement au contraire aujourd'hui
on pis les oeufs de tortues de plus
belle
on met ainsi en danger la survie même de
cette créature énorme extraordinaire
mais peut-être l'un tortue luth intel
heureusement des lieux de ponte inconnue
sur l'une ou l'autre il de corail perdu
dans l'océan
hors de la portée des hommes
m
si vous voulez découvrir une île du bout
du monde pourquoi pas celle ci aldabra
dans l'océan indien
la terre la plus proche et l'afrique à
400 km à l'ouest c'est en fait un groupe
d'îles qui font partie de l'ancien
continent de gone douanes a aujourd'hui
immergé celle ci est un atoll au sommet
d'un volcan et a jailli de la mer il y à
50 mille ans elle est devenue maintenant
le logis de milliers d'oiseaux de mer
tels ces frégates qui ont volé pendant
d'innombrables kilomètres pour venir se
poser sur les palétuviers qui pousse en
bordure de la côte
la plupart des plantes environnantes ont
dû venir à la surface de l'eau sous
forme de graines une noix de coco peu
flotté pendant plus de quatre mois avant
de mourir
celle ci est bien vivante et rien
n'empêcherait de croître en bordure de
la plage en grandissant les cocotiers
incline la tête par dessus la mer ainsi
les noix tombe à l'eau et à marée haute
elles s'en vont coloniser d'autres
villes
l'habitant le plus célèbre d'aldabra le
voici
c'est une tortue géante la plupart des
tortues flotte naturellement si l'une
d'entre elles se nourrissant sur un
palétuviers de la côte africaine venait
à être emportés par la mer elle pourrait
survivre suffisamment longtemps pour
être amenées par les courants jusqu'à
ces îles de l'océan indien et s'y
développer c'est d'ailleurs certainement
de cette manière que les ancêtres des
tortues géantes d'aldabra sont arrivés
ici la vie sur cette île et éprouvante
le soleil tropical frappe les animaux
menace de les cuire littéralement à
l'intérieur de leur carapace et les
trains accidentés ce genre sont
courantes
lorsque la chaleur augmente les tortues
partent à la recherche de l'un ou
l'autre abri susceptibles de leur
procurer de l'ombre ici et là sur
certaines plages balayé par le vent
pousse quelques bosquets qui a mis dix
sont encombrées de groupes de tortue
venus se réfugier là en attendant que
reviennent un peu de fraîcheur qui leur
permettra de repartir à la recherche des
feuilles comestibles constituant leur
repas cela fait donc 50 millénaire calda
bras a émergé en termes d'évolution ce
n'est pas une durée considérable
elle est suffisante cependant pour
apporter des modifications aux
caractéristiques physiques des animaux
qui vivent ici dans l'isolément ils se
sont transformés par rapport à leurs
ancêtres qui ont colonisé lille mais ils
sont aussi différents de leurs actuels
proches cousins partout dans le monde
plusieurs espèces d'oiseaux ont ainsi
subi des changements parfois léger mais
qui les rendent désormais uniques en
leur genre partout ailleurs l'ibis sacré
a les yeux sombres ici ils sont bleu
clair la crécerelle d'aldabra est plus
petite que celle de madagascar est le
swimming à houn hectares 1 2 lille un
plumage plus foncé que ses parents
d'afrique
les reptiles insulaire semble avoir une
tendance au gigantisme comme la tortue
d'aldabra un autre grand format célèbre
vit sur l'île de komodo en indonésie
c'est le plus grand lézard du monde
connu sous le nom de varans géants ou
dragon de komodo
il n'est pas difficile d'en rencontrer
il suffit d'une carcasse de chèvre de
préférence en état de décomposition
son odeur va les attirer à des
kilomètres à la ronde
on pensait autrefois que ces animaux
étaient exclusivement nécro fall qui se
nourrissait uniquement de charogne nous
savons maintenant qu'ils peuvent se muer
en tueur actifs il attaque et ils tuent
les chèvres les buffles on est même à
l'occasion l'homme si je peux les
approcher sans trop de risque c'est
qu'ils ont une très mauvaise vue et sont
pratiquement sourd il y supplay par de
bonnes qualités olfactives et gustatives
ainsi avec un peu de chance l'odeur de
ses chèvres mortes sera plus forte que
la mienne et ils ne s'intéresseront pas
à moins se sont fait les rois de cette
île dont ils sont les plus grands
prédateurs
il n'y a aucun animal ici à qui il
pourrait servir de proies et aucun non
plus qu'ils puissent leur disputer leur
nourriture
c'est sans doute ce qui dans leur
isolement a permis qu'il est atteint une
telle taille ils peuvent mesurer jusqu'à
3 mètres et peser une cinquantaine de
kilos et même davantage
comodo n'est pas comme aldabra anatole
qui s'est développée à partir du sommet
inondé d'un volcan mais elle est restée
rodez d'un volcan bien plus grands qui
s'est élevé à des centaines de mètres au
dessus du niveau de la mer les volcans
sont en effet à l'origine de la plupart
des îles isolées et les îles hawaï elle
même sont toutes volcanique la plus
grande et la plus récente d'entre elles
étant d'ailleurs encore en éruption
sur c'est odile s'accumulent les nuages
chargés d'humidité sur leur côté exposé
au vent les chutes de pluie tombe drue
des cours d'eau dévale les flancs des
montagnes traversant des couches peu
compact de cendres héros dans des
vallées profondes
ainsi contrairement aux apple qui
constitue une plateforme de corail de
sables et de roches s'élevant à quelques
centimètres seulement au dessus du
niveau de la mer c'est immense île
volcanique d'hawaï offre une grande
variété d'habitats à leurs colonisateurs
des hôtes pente froid de recouvertes de
cendres aux basses vallées bien irrigué
chaude et humide la du basalte récent
ellis plus loin d'antiques forêt
poussant sur d'anciennes coulées de lave
pour exploiter tout cela les éléments
colonisateurs ont adopté une multitude
de formes
le pal il a fait partie d'une grande
famille d'oiseaux hawaïen nectar ivor
lederrey pas ni d'idées leurs ancêtres
étaient sans doute des pins sont
transportés ici il y à des milliers
d'années par de fortes tempêtes
sur place ils ont développé plus de 30
espèces chacune avec son alimentation et
son habitat particulier le palis là se
nourrit de graines il possède pour les
briser un bec court et puissant
la maquille est un de ses parents son
corps est similaire mais son bec et plus
minces adapté à attraper de petits
insectes et asus et le nectar des fleurs
certaines espèces ont des plumages
chatoyant qui distingue le mal de la
femelle elle ne se croisent pas avec les
espèces cousine si bien qu'elles
deviennent de plus en plus spécifiques
ainsi la papal à tête rouge très voyante
un grand bec approprié à son régime
presque exclusivement composée de nectar
la co éco et qui possède une petite
crête de plumes blanches à la base du
bec à une alimentation mixte composée de
nectar et d'insectes
l'ieee oui vermillon a le bec long et
recourbées ce qui lui permet de sonder
profondément les fleurs en forme de
trompette
j
le plus attachant enfin et sans doute la
kia paula ou avec son bec splendide à
double fonction
la mandibule inférieure pic et écarte
les corses pour y déloger les insectes
la mandibule supérieur allongé sert à
les extraire
il utilise l'une et l'autre avec une
rare dextérité
des êtres humains ont débarqué à hawaï
et il y environ 15 cents ans c'étaient
des polynésiens de remarquables marin il
naviguait sur l'océan à bord de canoës à
flotteurs pouvant transporter plusieurs
centaines de passagers et dans la taille
était double de celle des canaux encore
utilisé de nos jours dans le pacifique
de leur base située à samois atteinte
par leurs ancêtres plus de mille ans
avant notre ère
ils ont colonisé les îles les unes après
les autres vers hawaii au nord et vers
l'île de pâques à l'est
mais leur plus grand périple ils l'ont
effectué au sud parcourant 6500
kilomètres d'océan pour atteindre la
nouvelle zélande
à leur arrivée il y à 15 cents ans la
terre qu'ils découvrirent là était très
différente de celle d'où ils venaient
avec des chaînes de montagnes et des
forêts inextricable contenant beaucoup
plus d'animaux et de plantes que les
atolls de corail
car cette terre fit autrefois partie
d'un plus vaste continent peuplé des
ancêtres de ses habitants actuels en
voici un
le tout à tara où ce fait nos dos un
reptile nocturne au troisième oeil
fonctionnel qui se nourrit de vers de
terre et d'insectes
il rassemble un lézard mais il est
plutôt apparentés aux dinosaures partout
ailleurs son espèce est éteinte depuis
longtemps
autre relique de ce continent disparu le
kiwi le kiwi n'a pas d'elle visible ni
de queue et il vit dans un trou au fond
duquel il pond un effet énorme le plus
grand proportionnellement à la taille
chez les oiseaux
ces longues plumes flottante ne lui
permettent pas de voler avec son air
hirsute lorsqu'il court sans bruit sur
le sol à la recherche de sa nourriture
il fait plutôt penser à un mammifère est
effectivement il a un peu fait fonction
de mammifères dans ces îles ou à
l'origine il n'en existait pas si son
bec l'apparentent aux oiseaux le kiwi
s'en sert de manière étrange il le
plongent profondément dans la terre pour
sentir les verts dont il se nourrit
comme le ferait un mammifère
depuis que la nouvelle zélande est
devenu il y à quelques millions d'années
ce groupe d'îles isolées des oiseaux
plus récents ils sont apparus comme
cette espèce de pigeons le guerrero où
ce perroquet le quai à ses ancêtres à
lui sont venues d'australie
il s'est adapté à la vie froid 2d haute
montagne où il se nourrit de baies de
racine et d'insectes mais aussi de
charogne comme un corbeau
le fait de vivre sur cette île un fait
subir à cette autre perroquet kakapo une
profonde mutation
il n'ya pas sur cette terre de
mammifères qui mangent des feuilles
cet oiseau en a fait son alimentation
est essentielle
cet animal nocturne extrêmement nerveuse
vite en effet de la végétation qu'il en
est il est particulièrement
caractéristique des animaux qui peuplent
l'île des fans sa seule défense et de se
mettre en arrêt comme il le fait là ils
ne bougent plus et il attend que passe
le danger le kakapo est aussi un géant
c'est le plus grand de tous les
perroquets il peut peser plus de trois
kilowatts et ce poids cette grande
taille sont à l'origine d'une troisième
caractéristique de tous les animaux de
l'île celui ci est un des plus
vulnérables
les ennuis du cac à pau ont commencé
quand sont arrivés les polynésiens qui
l'ont chassé il avait apporté avec eux
une sorte de raz qui dévasta ling
lorsque des siècles plus tard
débarquèrent des européens ils
introduisirent sur l'île d'autres tueurs
l'hermine et le chat de nos jours ne
demeure que quelques douzaines de kakapo
d'innombrables prédateurs ont été
importés ici des putois et des opossums
d'australie comme animaux familiers les
lapins d'europe pour leur chair et leur
fourrure et même des serres pour les
plaisirs de la chasse
tous sont eu un effet dévastateur sur
l'environnement allant même parfois en
débarrassant la terre de ses plantes
jusqu'à provoquer une sévère érosion du
sol
tant que l'homme continuera comme en
nouvelle zélande à ne pas se conduire en
protecteur active de la nature ces
étranges animaux seront condamnés comme
l'ont été leurs ancêtres
aujourd'hui disparus comme l'a été le
dodos de l'île maurice exterminés par
d'autres hommes les créatures que vous
trouvez sur ces îles ne passent pas
nécessairement tout leur temps ici
certaines comme ces voyageur infatigable
que sont les fous ne viennent que pour
se reposer de même que les frégates et
beaucoup d'autres oiseaux de mer ils
trouvent leur nourriture non sur les
îles où ils nichent mais dans la mer où
prolifèrent une autre communauté
complexe de plantes et d'animaux